while studying abroad I had one of the
wildest nights of my life and this is
that story
hello again alright so this story goes
back a few years I was a junior in
college spending a semester overseas
studying in Rome
now before we get to the juicy stuff I
should mention just how excited I was to
be in Rome I was a classics major many
of you are absolutely thinking I have no
idea what that means I'll tell you what
it means I was and will always be
fascinated by ancient Greek and Roman
civilization all things I'll definitely
need to know when I'm older ultimately
it doesn't really get much better than
spending six months in Rome
so this wild night starts maybe a month
into our semester it's Saturday night
and we collectively decide that we're
gonna take the plunge and explore the
nightlife see I say that like it's a
thing because it was a thing at least to
us back in the US all we knew was house
parties or dancing in someone's basement
we all get dressed up we want to look
cool we want to look hot we want to look
like this is not our first time doing
this fast forward to pulling up to the
club Wow
pulling up to the club who do I think I
am we get to the club and we head inside
we had chosen a place that sounded cool
but looking back on it just sounds dumb
it had a dumb name like inspire or
radiate or steam whatever the names not
important so we're in the club and we're
actually having a really great time
we're dancing we're drinking it's not
crowded for some reason we're living it
up obviously now I understand that
people in Rome don't really start
heading out until midnight 1:00 a.m. and
here we are multiple drinks deep by
11:00 it got to a point you know where
we're like taking pictures of ourselves
a couple group shots a couple selfies
cute cute but when we immediately look
at those pictures there were very clear
signals it was time to pack it in it's
making us laugh obviously but then we
really take a closer look at one of my
friends we zoomed into her eyes and
they're open and sure they're pointed in
the direction of the camera but there is
no soul in those eyes this point in the
story it's probably two o'clock in the
morning let's get everyone together and
get the hell out of here so we rally our
group head outside and
is a complete madhouse there's people
everywhere waiting to get in security
guards are yelling cars are honking it's
complete sensory overload how do we get
home we've just got to get home
thinking back I don't really understand
now this next part is possible but it's
what happened there was not a single
taxi in sight
yeah there were cars everywhere but none
of them seemed to be just a regular taxi
suddenly this man leaning on his car
gets our attention
it says taxi on the side of the car but
it doesn't look like other taxis he's
just shouting at us in Italian we were
all just getting the hang of very basic
Italian so most of what he was saying
was just going right over our heads he's
opening the door and motioning for us to
get in everyone starts heading towards
the car but in my head I'm thinking this
guy is a hundred percent trying to rip
us off I try asking him how much it'll
cost to take us to where we were staying
he says something like don't worry don't
worry pay later
he's bordering on aggressive I don't
know he just seemed like a shady guy now
let's pump the brakes on this video
because I can hear everyone yelling why
are you getting in this car and I'm
sorry to say we all pile in the back
seat I know I know to be honest my main
concern at this point in the night was
just getting us home I didn't care at
what cost so again as we pull away I
muster a little bit more Italian to say
how much is this going to cost
it seems very annoyed with my question
and fires back up race everyone in the
car can feel the tension we're getting
ripped off someone else summons the
courage to try and negotiate through
little bits of English and mostly
Italian we're able to make out that if
we don't like the price he'll kick us
out and leave us honestly it was scary
this clearly wasn't a real taxi yes we
were dumb enough to get in it but we
were stuck we didn't say anything else
and it seemed we all just silently
agreed to take the ride home and we'll
pay what we have to we quietly do a
quick money change okay we have more
than enough we're gonna be fine ripped
off but fine we are winding through
these streets this guy is driving fast
he's talking on the phone I have no
how far away wheeler nothing looked
familiar everyone in the car starts
trading worried glances at each other
this didn't feel right
suddenly my friend in the middle puts
her hands up to her mouth we'd been in
college long enough to know what that
means there's some fuel come in before
any of us can intervene with words of
encouragement rolling the windows down
she erupts sorry about this next part
because their hands are in front of her
mouth this directs the throw-up in a 180
degree plane parallel vomit fountain
directly onto myself and my friend on
the other side of the car we try to be
quick with the cover-up the guy driving
already hates us sorry again we're
scooping the throw-up and I don't know
what we were trying to do but the panic
was setting in the driver slowly looks
into his rearview mirror and really gets
a good look at everything that's
happening behind him he immediately
pulls the car over and is furious
he's second the car stops he jumps out
whips the door open and is he yelling at
us to get out we're all terrified
someone has the common sense to pull
some money out and hand it to him it
clearly wasn't enough he takes the money
but then he also takes his phone out
something to note we had driven to an
area that didn't feel like the city
whether it was a park or something but
we were essentially alone with this guy
some of us are trying to reason with him
some of us are trying to clean the puke
out of the back seat and my friend who
threw up she's just like doing her best
we're spiraling maybe he's calling the
cops
but as he's talking he's saying the name
Marco a lot who is Marco is Marco on the
police force is Marco his boss I don't
know it doesn't make sense for him to
even be talking to the police is this
cab even legal but he is a really
shouting on the phone and gesturing at
us we need to start talking exit
strategy he had our money we cleaned the
car out the best we could we just needed
to get home
once again no real words exchanged but
we were all clearly on the same page he
slowly start to walk away down the dark
road and he hurries past us with his
arms out blocking us we're trying to
give him more money we don't have much
left we're apologizing he is so angry
all the while still on the phones
staring daggers at us and I got the
sense that whoever he was talking to on
that phone was on their way here now
now I truly truly do not know what came
over me
in this next moment all I knew was that
we were not safe and we were not going
to stick around to see what happens next
somehow in Italian I calmly asked who
were you talking to on the phone he
gives me this bone-chilling smile and
all he says is me amico Marco so I say
say ciao to Marco and grab the phone out
of this man's hands and throw it into
the bushes
yeah a hundred percent true there's a
second of silence which is broken by my
previously dead eyed friend shouting run
someone throws the last handful of money
that we have and we all take off now I'm
assuming if you're still watching you're
enjoying the story but the craziest part
hasn't even happened yet so don't go
anywhere
oddly enough the man doesn't chase us
which makes me think he was trying to
scare us or made enough money not to
care anymore who knows so sweaty
panting covered and throw up we make our
way to an intersection where at least
there are streetlights cars buildings of
course there's taxis everywhere now but
all the drivers took one look at us and
floored it all hope seems lost no one
had any idea what to do this night was a
disaster now this next part is not a
hundred percent true it's a thousand
percent true a limousine pulls up next
to us so for those of you keeping track
this is now the second time a mysterious
car has appeared in this story the back
window rolls down and it's I don't know
how else to say this a beautifully
elegant young Italian couple they were
dressed like they were coming home from
a ball
or something and we we looked like we
fell off the back of a train in
exceptional English they asked where are
we trying to go I don't even remember
who did the talking I think we were all
just processing what just happened and
what was currently happening these
magnificent angelic people opened the
door and tell us to hop in they'll take
us wherever we need to go what yeah I
don't know either the drive home we tell
them what happened they agreed it
sounded scary they stopped at a store to
buy us water and pastries and eventually
they drop us off at our apartment just
like they said they would we get inside
safe and sound and just pass out from
exhaustion within the past hour it had
gone from locked up abroad to the
Princess Diaries so so so insane if my
fancy limo angels are watching thank you
for being so kind to us and to our
driver none of us are proud of what
happened and we're sorry for the mess
and to Marco sweet Marco I'm sorry we
never met
ciao
[Music]